incoming bonus content
hi i'm casey wilson and i'm danielle
schneider and we are gonna do the best
friend challenge
i'm doing a tithe
okay
okay one two three
i had portia first
and so yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
but portia is the greatest one she's the
greatest hospital i mean i think these
two are the greatest yes and i would
have said sonia too if i knew we could
do two i would have said something
hayden
[Music]
all my talents are they're out there
yeah the world enjoys all my talents so
it's hard to pick one talent we have so
many
okay ready
what did you say perfect pitch
that's not hidden okay well i don't have
perfect decorating
decorator thank you
you have beautiful designs like designs
you know whatever i wish i could put
that yeah beautiful design
one two three
[Laughter]
when you are someone you run them yeah
but just the essence the essence the raw
essence
okay
not a dog
okay i just find dog people like their
dogs will jump up in your face and lick
you all over and they're like do you
mind dogs it's like get your dog off me
i put sexy links how dare you don't even
put a little
you couldn't pick a lynx out of a lineup
i was gonna put ann either but aunt evan
i don't know
that was a strip that's well that was a
hard i feel like mine was the most right
yeah you're right and that was a little
bit extra for you
[Music]
you